a lot of us are having weird thoughts
these days we're doing some strange
things
we're all getting a little off-kilter
during this quarantine
and so i asked some of my celebrity pals
yes i have celebrity pals
i got some my celebrity pals maybe you
could come clean and share
some of the weird thoughts and weird
things you've been doing and they have
and a little thing we call quarantine
confessions
quarantine confessions
ed
after my daughter goes to bed i wander
around the house
aimlessly and whenever i pass a mirror i
say
evening sheriff confession
look um i'll be honest not everyone in
hollywood is social distancing
last night i went to a sneeze orgy at
the rock's house
confession remember that baby from the
hangover
such a diva confession
i have a name for every plant in my
house
it's gary confession
i told my daughter that this pandemic is
an early sign that
santa's not happy with her confession
i regret judging my dog for rubbing his
butt on the carpet
it actually feels really good quarantine
confession